mr depp hasn't looked at you once this
entire trial has he
not that i've noticed no
you've looked at him though many times
haven't you
yes i have
you know exactly why mr deb won't look
back at you don't you
i do
he promised you he would never you would
never see his eyes again isn't that true
i don't recall if he said that
one of the last times you ever saw mr
depp was when you met him in san
francisco
in july of 2016 right
that was the second to last time i saw
him yes
and this was after you had publicly
accused him of domestic violence
i got my restraining order before that
yes
and this is after you had obtained the
domestic violence restraining order
against him that's correct
let's please play plaintiff's exhibit
one two two nine
[Music]
yes
[Music]
no because i'm nothing to you and i will
always do nothing to you
come on
you're not my shrimp
[Music]
[Music]
my eyes you will not see my eyes again
that's you and mr death and that
recording that is
and this is from when you and mr dot met
in san francisco in july of 2016 right
yes that's what it sounds like that was
in the hotel we met once after that as
well
this is after you publicly accused him
of domestic abuse
yes and got my tro yeah and he tells you
you will not see my eyes again doesn't
he
uh yes he does in that recording and he
kept that promise hasn't he
as far as i know he cannot look at me
he won't look at you right mister
he can't
one of the first questions your counsel
asked you on direct is why are you here
do you remember that
i do
let's please play plane to exhibit 357a
which is already in evidence your honor
and for the record it's 21 22 through
think tell the 2140 johnny tell them
johnny depp i find that man i'm i'm a
victim of domestic violence
you know it's a fair fight it seems how
many people believe or side with you
that's your voice on that recording
right yes it is and you were speaking
with mr depp
yes
and you said to mr dab quote
you can tell
you can please tell people that it was a
fair fight and see what the jury and the
judge think tell the world johnny
tell them johnny depp i johnny depp a
man
a victim two of domestic violence end
quote that's what you said right
i was saying it to the man who beat me
up yes
miss her do you testified to an incident
in march of 2013 where mr depp hit you
in the face multiple times do you recall
that
that's correct and you testified quote
you don't know how many times he hit you
in the face
that's correct
so mr depp hit you in the face multiple
times while he was wearing rings on this
occasion correct
which occasion and march are you
referencing you weren't the testimony
that you gave
on day 15 of this trial
march of 2013. you weren't specific as
to the day
there were several incidents
the one where he hit you several times
in the face
uh
there were there was so i'm sorry just
so i understand better there were
several incidents in march which one are
you asking me about the time that he hit
you several times in the face wearing
rings
well
he pretty much in 2013.
right
what are you asking me i'm sorry he was
wearing rings on that occasion
i pretty much always knew him to wear
rings okay let's please pull up
defendants exhibit 170
a which is already in evidence your
honor
you testified this is a picture you took
after that incident right misheard
yes that was one where he grabbed me
and hit you in the face so many times
that you don't remember
isn't that correct that's correct
and there's no injuries to your face in
this picture are there
not that
this picture shows
and there's no medical records
reflecting that you sought treatment
after this alleged incident either
i did not seek medical treatment at this
time
you testified that you were also raped
with a liquor bottle in australia right
misheard
yes
you testified you bled from your vagina
as a result of that sexual assault
yes
there aren't any medical records
reflecting that you sought medical
treatment for any of these injuries are
there
i did not seek uh medical treatment
after australia no not for the rape
no i did not want to tell anyone
not for the cuts
no not for the injuries to your face i
didn't need to
sure let's take a look at defendants
exhibit 1090 which is already in
evidence
you took this photograph right miss
heard that's correct
and you testified that this was taken in
tokyo in july of 2013 correct
yes
so you decided to take a picture of mr
deb asleep on the floor
he was passed out
and i took a picture of him because he
uh wouldn't remember
he claimed he didn't pass out that way
and
sometimes security would
carry him like a baby into bed get him
changed
and he would be none the wiser so i
started taking pictures of it so that he
knew
that it was real that it had gotten this
bad
sir does this refresh a recollection
that you did in fact send this picture
to your friend rocky pennington yes i
did
[Music]
he sent it to her
on august 7 2014 at 11 24 p.m correct
that is correct
so you sent miss pennington this picture
of mr depp with ice cream spilled on him
right that is correct and you wrote
quote this is what i've been dealing
with and quote did i read that right you
did read that right that's correct and
this is you protecting mr dub
that is me getting support from my best
friend this is you supporting mr depp
this is me getting support from my best
friend i also need support
you weren't afraid the the monster would
get upset that you took this picture
this was um opiate johnny
this is a different
version of him this is opiate on the nod
johnny and you weren't afraid that
opiate johnny or the monster as you
called him would get upset that you sent
this picture to your friend well he's
all of those things
he of course he could get upset and of
course that's scary to me of course
but it stopped you from sending this
picture to your friend did it
why would it
so in this october 2018 interview you
said that you had quote donated
end quote your entire divorce settlement
to charity right that's correct and in
fact your exact words were quote seven
million in total was donated to
i split it between the aclu and the
children's hospital of los angeles end
quote right that's correct i made that
statement as soon as i got a divorce and
we reached the settlement that's when i
pledged it right then
and you say this because you quote
wanted nothing end quote that is correct
but you hadn't donated your entire
entire seven million dollars
settlement to charity at that point had
you that's incorrect
sitting here today ms heard you still
haven't donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
isn't that right
incorrect i pledged the entirety
of the settlement seven
you have not donated the seven million
dollars donated now pledged donated the
seven million dollars divorce settlement
to charity
i use pledge and donation
synonymous with one another but i don't
miss herd
i don't use it synonymously that's how
donations are paid misheard respectfully
that's not my question
as of today
you have not paid 3.5 million dollars of
your own money to the aclu yes or no
i have not yet
you had all of the seven million dollars
for 13 months before mr depp sued you
and you chose not to pay it to the
charities you pledged it to is that
correct i disagree with your
characterization of that
most of the money that was donated to
the aclu and chla in your name came from
someone else isn't that right
i don't know what you mean by most stuff
well at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the aclu in
your name wasn't paid by you right
uh i believe elon made a donation in my
honor on one one of the years yeah and
it didn't come out of your 7 million
divorce settlement right no nor did it
count towards my pledge
and at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the
children's hospital of los angeles and
your name wasn't paid by you either
right those were made at the same time
and it didn't come out of your 7 million
divorce settlement nor did it count to
my
3.5 obligation those 500 000 payments
came from your new boyfriend elon musk
right
uh he i don't know if he was a new
boyfriend at the time
you got him to pay part of what you
promised to these two charities didn't
you incorrect
because you wanted to keep at least some
of the seven million dollar divorce
settlement for yourself right i'm very
wrong about that
i think this
if you're honored
this is a good breaking point okay
that's fine